okay so the topic of this video are one
of the categories of organic molecules
called proteins now there's four types
of organic molecules proteins
carbohydrates lipids and nucleic acids I
have a separate video for each this
videos is devoted to proteins so let's
get started so a few basics first about
proteins first of all proteins are used
in a wide variety of cellular functions
you know later in the school year we're
going to go into photosynthesis and a
lot more detail but from the animation
you can see that photosynthesis requires
three basic reactants sunlight carbon
dioxide and water and through the
process of photosynthesis we'll create
oxygen and glucose but in order to make
oxygen and glucose very special proteins
are required along the way we'll go into
that in more detail here's another
example where proteins are used in
cellular functions the mitochondria does
a process called cellular respiration
the cell the mitochondria is an
organelle a part of your cell and it's
it's job is to take in glucose and
produce a molecule called ATP it's an
energy molecule so later on in the
school year we'll learn about this in
more detail later on in the school year
we're going to learn about a process
called DNA replication this is the
process where one DNA molecule is copied
into two DNA molecules this process
requires the use of proteins so another
example of a cell process that requires
proteins is a process called
transcription and in this process RNA is
created now in my picture there's DNA
there are special proteins that will
break apart a DNA molecule and then
these orange RNA molecules will attach
to the DNA once that happens the orange
RNA will break away and eventually we'll
tell you what it does in another video
but there are special proteins that will
join the DNA back together so there's
all kinds of needs for proteins and the
last one I want to quickly mention later
on in the school year we're going to
learn about a cellular process called
translation
in this process a ribosome is going to
make proteins with the help of various
now with the help of of other kinds of
proteins called enzymes so a ribosome is
going to gather an amino acid and
another and another and another and
another and another and another and it's
going to link these amino acids into a
big long chain that's what a protein is
a big chain of amino acids but all of
these processes require proteins and so
I brought up earlier in another video
monomers and polymers if you recall that
a monomer is a small organic molecule
and in the world of proteins we call the
monomer of a protein and amino acid now
there is there's 20 different kinds of
amino acids for instance leucine is one
of the 20 different kinds of amino acids
valine is another glycine is another
alanine is another and so here's four
different amino acids but like I said a
moment ago there's 20 different kinds of
amino acids so when a bunch of amino
acids bond together into a big long
chain we call this a polypeptide so this
big long chain of 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
this big long chain of 10 amino acids
right here makes up one single
polypeptide polypeptide is a large
organic molecule made from smaller amino
acids well proteins are going to be
formed from a collection of polypeptides
so here in green is another polypeptide
this polypeptide is a little smaller you
can see it's only made from 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 amino acids now my notes say that
proteins are formed from a collection of
polypeptide so watch this these two
polypeptides will bind together and then
when they attach they're going to twist
and fold themselves into a very specific
shape and then and only then do we call
that overall molecule a protein so
proteins are made from maybe only one
polypeptide
proteins are made from two polypeptides
other proteins are made from three
polypeptides other proteins are made
from four polypeptides so proteins can
be rather large and so it's this exact
arrangement of amino acids that will
determine what type of protein it is and
what the job does if one single amino
acid is changed and in the wrong
location that really can have drastic
impacts on the overall protein you might
have heard you might have heard of a
disease called sickle-cell disease
because of one single wrong protein
excuse me because of one single wrong
amino acid red blood cells are miss
shape and they almost look like bananas
and people who have sickle cell disease
so it can be a very life-threatening
disease all because of the wrong
placement of a single amino acid
structure the molecular structure well
it's organic and so you know that
there's going to be a central carbon
atom so there is our central carbon
carbon atom flashing attached to the
carbon member in another video we said
that carbon can bind up to four
different times so we're going to have
four different molecules are four
different excuse me four different atoms
are going to be bonded to this one
carbon here in the center so on the left
in my animation we have the first group
I want to mention this three atom group
right here this nh-2 group is what we
call an amino group NH two is what we
found amino group and amino acids have
an amino group they also notice attached
to the carbon also is a single hydrogen
all twenty amino acids have a single
hydrogen the next thing I want to
mention all twenty amino acids have this
COOH group called a carboxyl group and I
hope you see how it got the name
carboxyl carb
implies carbon axial implies oxygen so
if you just mush the word carbon and
oxygen together you get a carboxyl all
amino acids have a carboxyl group and
the last thing the last atom that's
attached to our central carbon
is what we simply just called the our
group or you might even see it called
the side group now our is not really
stand for anything on the periodic table
the joke is that it just stands for the
rest of the molecule and what I mean by
that there's 20 different amino acids
but every single one every amino acid
has a different our group has a
different group of molecules right here
where it says the letter R and I'll show
you a few examples right now so here we
have our very generic diagram that I
just shown and I highlighted the R group
in red
now there's an amino acid by the name of
glycine it's our group is simply a
hydrogen atom that's it so the R group
can be very simple like in the example
of glycine right here well let me put
the generic diagram of an amino acid
back up here here we have our R group a
very generic amino acid diagram now
there's another enemy there's another
amino acid by the name of alanine it's
our group looks like this a carbon and
three hydrogen's but notice how
everything else is the same when you
compare alanine to the previous example
here's one more exam so let's reset the
amino acid to our generic structure with
the R group highlighted in red there is
an amino acid by the name of valine it's
our group is a little more complex you
can see right here what it's our group
looks like but notice the rest of the
amino acid is unchanged it still has the
NH two amino group
it still has the COOH carboxyl group the
only thing different between valine and
the previous two examples is they have a
different R group and so here's four of
the twenty amino acids that exist serine
glycine alanine and valine and my
question on top says what differ is
between these four amino acids notice
they each have an amino group NH two
that's the same Sirians amino group is
the same as glycine alanine unveiling
notice they each have highlighted in red
color here
they each have a carboxyl group Sirians
carboxyl group is the same as glycine
same as alanine same as
failing so what makes these four
different is they're our group this is
this highlighted in green here is our
our group of these four different amino
acids so as I wrap up this video I want
to give special attention to a category
of protein called enzymes so enzymes are
a type of protein now in my picture
I have a big chain of glucose right here
so there's four glucose is bonded
together to make one big molecule for
instance this might be starch a
polysaccharide called starch but enzymes
what their job is and there are
thousands of different types of enzymes
but enzymes job in general is to lower
the energy that is needed to start a
chemical reaction so the reason why we
have enzymes is when cells perform their
cellular jobs and cells do their
functions if we did not have enzymes
cells would need a lot more energy to
achieve their needs to achieve their
goals so with the use of enzymes
cellular needs are performed a lot more
efficiently they lower the energy needed
to start a chemical reaction so for
instance one example where enzymes are
required is simply the digesting and
breaking down of food again in my
picture pretend that's a molecule of
starch made from for glucose is bonded
together well there's an enzyme by the
name of amylase amylases is shown here
symbolic of the animated scissors now I
can tell just by the spelling of the
word amylase that amylase is an enzyme
enzymes typically end with the suffix
ASE so if I see a molecule with the
suffix ending of ASE good chance that
that molecule is an enzyme and so what
amylase will do will break that for
glucose molecule into two smaller
fragments that's what I mean by breaking
down food so when you take in large food
molecules the enzyme called amylase will
break it break that large food molecule
into smaller fragments so enzymes not
only be they break down food like we
just said but they can also build
molecules for instance we mentioned this
a few moments ago they can build
proteins enzymes are used to build
proteins here we have two amino acids
how are these two amino acids going to
stick together with one another to form
a larger polypeptide well what happens
is there's a chemical reaction called a
dehydration synthesis watch this a
dehydration synthesis reaction watch
this these two amino acids will bind
together and water will be removed
that's why it's called a dehydration
synthesis reaction that's because water
was taken out what I didn't show in the
animation were the cutting of the
original bonds by the by by enzymes
enzymes will help break the original
bonds in order to build up this larger
protein enzymes are very sensitive to
their environment so enzymes work really
really well when the enzyme is in its
normal environment but enzymes are very
sensitive to pH enzymes are very
sensitive to body temperature so in my
example if you have a high fever enzymes
lose their ability to work now right now
a person has pretend a normal body
temperature of 98.6 degrees and so that
enzyme called amylase does its job just
fine it will break apart those those
four glucose that that grouping of four
glucose it broke apart into those two
fragments and that's its job it worked
wonderfully however let's pretend a
person has a fever of 102 point 5
degrees so notice how the enzyme is not
the scissors are not animated they're
not cutting anymore so what happens is
when enzymes are outside of their normal
temperature they lose their ability to
function so because the enzymes aren't
cutting there's no chemical reaction and
so if the body temperature is not
brought back down to normal then cell
reactions stop functioning and cells
start to die and overall the person
could die another thing I want to
mention is that enzymes are very
specific in their actions again here's
that molecule of starch made from those
four
glucose is binded together and there's
the same amylase animation we saw a
moment ago the enzyme called amylase
it's very very specific it will break
that for glucose molecule called starch
into those two smaller fragments and it
does that wonderfully but watch this so
look at this example the molecules
change the little bit it used to be
glucose glucose glucose glucose for
glucose is binded together but now
there's a couple fructose --is where
there used to be glucoses amylase notice
how the scissors are not cutting amylase
is not able to break these molecules
down amylase is very very specific there
would have to be another different
enzyme to break apart what you see in
the picture because amylase just can't
do it
so because amylase can't cut right there
there's no chemical reaction the only
way there would be a chemical reaction
is if there was a separate new enzyme
that was capable to break down that
molecule in the picture but emily's sure
can't do it and lastly I want to mention
that enzymes are reusable and what I
mean by that here we have two starches
and starch on the Left those four
glucose is bonded together the starch on
the right those four glucose is bonded
together and so what I mean by the
reusable here is our enzyme amylase it
will break down the first starch but
what I mean by it's reusable it can also
be used to break down that other starch
and if there's more the enzyme can be
used to break down a third starch break
down a fourth starch so again this helps
to save energy instead of having to
build amylase over and over and over and
over and over again one amylase molecule
can be used I don't want to say
indefinitely but can be used many many
many times and so there you go we've
reached the end if you're in my biology
class pause the video I'd love to check
your and try these answers that or try
these questions on a separate sheet of
paper I'd love to check your answers
either before school or after school one
day good luck